when you see us in tears on the show for
example you know it's not because we're
sitting there emotionally involved in
their careers no
we're sitting there as parents
for example you'll ask a very simple
question tell us about your growing up
tell us about your family life and the
lady will say
we're homeless
now that has nothing to do with singing
that has to do with real life so when
you see us sitting there the first thing
we say is please God be able to sing
because the last thing I want to do is
send you away yes and most of the time
we know they can't but what we do now is
when's the last time they left any parts
of that town they were in never
so we'll say things like
you know what we're going to send you to
Hollywood